that's where I'm from every now and then
people ask me oh that's hard to see down
there isn't it but I am from northern
Greenland place called Curtis walk on
the island of disco in the middle of
disco Bay and born in the 60s I'm old as
the keynote yesterday was saying we're
all getting older I'm sorry leading the
pack here I think almost there might be
one or two older in the room but not
many this is me still me
family my parents on the dogsled it's a
pretty crazy place to grow up
this was the house that's the view in
the summer time of the house and the
backyard and the front yard I guess me
hacking more hacking getting older still
living in northern Greenland very very
crazy place so this is before the 25
years starts but there's a sort of the
getting there then in the 80s started
hacking on actual computers although not
sure you can call this a real computer
and had a cell it had 1024 bytes of
memory 1k native that big box on the
back was a 16 K memory expansion crazy
completely crazy compared to what my son
has today to play with and hack on it's
nuts like 20 modems that know them I
mean this was me growing up this was my
internet if you will there was nothing
80s or 90s we started getting closer
with gopher when I was in the university
I used gopher reading research papers at
the bottom of the research papers you
could scroll down with the cursor keys
and click on links to other research
papers that was as close to the web as
I ever saw in university after I
graduated University in October 1994
mosaic was released first graphical web
browser and here the 25 year counter
starts for me this changed everything
right and not just for me for everybody
and it wasn't just me that I could see
that this would change things everybody
around at the time playing with this
stuff and having had uucp addresses and
playing with Usenet and bulletin boards
it was very easy to see that this was
going to change the world so I started
hacking on this stuff right away the web
looked like this
CGI pins written in C not a pretty sight
and not something you'd want to maintain
having HTML inside your C programs was
not a nice thing to have lots of people
starting using CGI p.m. Perl module for
writing CGI programs and I didn't like
this any better still programming your
HTML in some other language which to me
made it impossible to separate the
business logic from the templating and
the look and feel the layout of the page
and I wanted those two separate which
people especially saw that the the non
PHP types tend to chuckle at because PHP
is quite well known for mushing it all
together that wasn't the original intent
my intent was to have very very simple
templating so that's the same example
written in Perl and then see here would
look look like this
in the PHP template in system right
it looks like HTML with just a few tags
here and there we need the dynamic
content from the form submit
my grand scheme was to write a capi for
the web so abstract away all the web
specific things that you needed to know
to get your business logic up online and
the idea was that you would create these
template tags you would add your tags to
the templating system by writing small C
functions so here's an example of like a
cosine function that you might want to
add
they were stack based so the tag would
pass with the the templating system
would read this find this tag and CA
okay this is tag name Coast's there's an
argument the input it would pop thee or
push the input argument onto the stack
in the C code we pop off any arguments
from the stack call whatever function
and then push the result back onto the
stack and that's how it'll work and you
wouldn't need to know anything about how
to parse cookies of HTTP requests get
method variables post variables all that
stuff was taken care of for you
all you had to do was write so there's a
core piece of your business logic and C
and then expose that business logic to
your templating system much like you do
and things like smarty and things where
you assign values to variables and
expose that to a templates except you
are assigning it from C and this is how
I like to solve the web problem back
then and I did figure other people might
like to solve it this way too I was
completely wrong
nobody wanted to write C code and it was
a bit distressing to me at the time
actually I was trying to convince people
people would email me and they would say
this PHP thing is cool you have all
these tags built in and I included a
whole bunch of demo applications and
tags and things and they would say well
we need and we also need a tag that does
this we can't figure how to do this I
would stroke this so easy this is the C
code to do that and they would say thank
you and then now we need this one we
can't figure out how to do this
and I would do it and there would they
would trick me into building their site
basically and it just kept going and
going and then people started asking for
more and more logic in the templating
system so recursion things like that
that I didn't really see any need for in
a templating system and I wasn't all
that good at writing a language parser I
mean the templating system was pretty
simple it was just a state machine
you're either inside the template tag or
you weren't and it was very very simple
in the beginning you couldn't do math
you couldn't do anything in the template
system but people starting asking for
stuff like that like just math itself
it's really really hard if you're
programming it right because I always
parsing it I was wasn't using yak or
Lacs or anything I was just parsing it
left to right and you get one plus two
times three you can't do that left to
right you get the wrong answer okay you
have to do the multiplication before the
addition and the whole thing just kind
of gets really complicated really really
quickly when you're just trying to build
a state machine in your head that parses
an entire language but it was very
obvious that people preferred just
working in the template existence and I
shifted the focus completely away from
necessarily I mean I got the language
working I read a book on yak on yak and
Lex and kind of figured out how to build
a somewhat usable parser where it could
offload like the math handling yak and
Lex could take care of all that for me
for the most part so I got a parser that
kind of saw that worked okay and then I
worked a lot on the ecosystem in the
early days making sure that all the
different pieces could talk to each
other because really what you need you
need a robust system where you can talk
to all the different things that you
need to talk to you don't necessarily
need a beautiful language to program in
you can have them best language in the
world and if it doesn't talk to your
Oracle database where all your data is
there's absolutely no point right and
that's really what I focused on I
focused on making sure that the four
pieces that are critical so a pipe web
application would work well together so
an operating system a web server
scripting language and some kind of
back-end datastore a shared datastore
and it really wasn't an accident
lamp came around and it wasn't just me I
mean I I got the ball rolling but there
were lots of people that helped out in
getting the whole ecosystem running well
and some of the things over the years
like initially mod PHP was the big one
embedding PHP into Apache was huge
because other languages specially back
then were faster and better but they all
ran as CG is Perl was way faster than
early PHP but not once you embed PHP
into Apache by the time use fork and
exec a Perl process and wait for the
interpreter to fire up on every single
request PHP was already done the fact
that by the time Perl got started it was
really fast didn't help them because
their overhead was so high
being CGI it took them a couple of years
but the mod Perl eventually came around
they figured out hey we need to do this
- we need to embed Perl into Apache and
they completely messed it up because
they made it way too powerful I only
hooked the content generation hook in
Apache which is when the patch Eve has
figured out where's the document root
and where's the script and everything
then it would call PHP and say okay for
this particular file the handler is PHP
run PHP and send the content back with
mod Perl you could hook all the
different request hooks in Apache
including the path translation hook
which is the hook that says for this
particular request this is the document
root that meant that if you are on the
Virtual host on an Apache server and you
had mala parallax's you could steal the
request from every
the virtual host if he wanted to simply
by hooking the path translate hook and
pointing everything to your document
route and that meant that ISPs could not
offer mod Perl as a shared virtual host
alongside other clients in a single
Apache instance so if you came to a nice
piece that I would like mod Perl they
would say okay that'll be six hundred
dollars a month because back then we
also didn't have VMs contained there was
anything like that so you had to have a
separate physical bare metal box for
more mod Perl whereas on PHP you could
put three thousand customers on one
machine versus one mod Perl customer so
it died ISPs I mean ISPs would offer it
but nobody would want to pay a hundred
times more for Perl verses PHP I also
pushed really hard for a long time in
the beginning for the whole concept of a
shared nothing perfect sandbox model
where we fire everything up and take
tear everything down after request no
state is stored in PHP server side if
there is any sort of state on a per
machine basis that's something that you
did as application developers and also
multi-threading
I've always been firmly against any sort
of multi-threading because it just gets
too complicated we as humans are not
smart enough to write complex multi
thread safe code and when you link in
dozens and dozens and dozens of
third-party libraries and expect them
all to be thread safe it's just no way
if the scope is limited enough you can
write thread safe code but for something
like a general purpose glue language
like PHP there's just absolutely no way
you can get that right and also if you
have multiple threads if one screws up
which it will it will take down all the
other concurrent threads even today 25
years later at Etsy
where I work we run PHP and every now
and then there's a segfault it's rare
maybe one or two a week and I have no
idea why they happen but I don't really
care it's like once a one every three
billion requests will cause a segfault
and the pachi just says ok we'll start
another child who cares we move on
that makes it robust if we're in a
multi-threaded server and one child dies
or that causes any sort of memory
corruption that entire group of
concurrent connections are gonna die as
well which is not a good thing h/h VM
stepped into that one as well because
they they do multi-threaded concurrent
requests model are the things I worked
on in the sort of the ecosystem bucket
was the SQL lipid clause because I was
using a database called M SQL this was
pre MySQL 1990 late 94 the 95 or so I
was using mini SQL super smart guy named
David Hughes in Australia had written
this tiny little database that was
perfect for the web it's SQL was quite
limited it didn't have I don't think it
even have joins back in the early days
but just as a very simple datastore that
was perfect for simple web SQL queries
it was awesome
but it had no way of limiting the number
of results you got back from a query so
if you made the fatal mistake of doing a
select star on a table that had a couple
hundred thousand rows in it and because
we didn't have any sort of 10-gig
network cards back then you were waiting
for awhile for that entire result set to
come across and if you only need it the
first one it really sucked waiting for
400,000 rows and then just showing the
first one right so it was super obvious
to add some kind of limiter to these SQL
queries so I arbitrarily
named it limit and patched it in got it
accepted upstream in the thing and that
has caused limit now to propagate
through many many databases I find kind
of interesting and it's not standard at
all there's an ANSI SQL standard there's
no sign of limit in the in the standard
still also on the isp side like maximum
execution time memory limit and safe
mode helped ISPs feel a little bit
better about offering PHP because they
could say well even if you write a while
true PHP script that kind of hurts the
server but because there's maximum
execution time with just CPU time based
after that menu CPU seconds it'll just
get killed off so it was somewhat okay
for an isp to put thousands of PHP users
on the same server still not ideal but
in the early days of the web it was very
sort of Wild West you kind of hoped for
the best
that with just about everything you were
doing some of the things over the years
that people keep asking me about I
case-insensitive function names it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense today
but for all of these decisions you have
to take the context in mind this is from
25 years ago this one when the web first
started there was a huge religious
battle on whether HTML tags should be
upper case lower case or even mixed case
because my template existing wanted to
fit in this world and I didn't want to
take sides I wanted everybody no matter
what their religion was to be able to
use PHP templates these tags which were
essentially just function names in the
early days there was no point making
them case sensitive because then people
would complain that they couldn't fit
into their style that they were used to
in their HTML and that has just stuck
now when HTML when everybody did finally
sort of get to lowercase
I probably should have switched it but I
remember thinking about doing it
97 maybe 96 and I remember thinking this
will affect hundreds of sites as a man I
can't inconvenience hundreds of sites
looking back now like I should have
inconvenienced a couple of hundred sites
at the time but I had no idea I had
absolutely no idea I figured at every
sort of at every point along the way I
figured there was about six months of
life left in PHP because that's about
the amount of time I thought it would
take for somebody to write something
real that could replace it and that also
would work for me and I kept waiting for
something to come along that I could use
that would work for me and nothing did
idiots came out with stuff like
ColdFusion and another thing is I looked
at god what the hell this isn't how you
solve the web problem and then and
confusion became popular even like wow
this is this is just a weird world we're
in I guess I'm stuck with this naming
inconsistencies there aren't actually
any the naming in PHP is perfectly
consistent just not the way you expect
dollar signs people have complained a
bit I even have people saying why dollar
this is very American centric come on
Global's this is actually one of the
better decisions I think very few
languages do it this I'm straight any
languages actually hand the Global's the
way PHP does this came out of a huge
debugging debacle I had pre PHP I was at
a company called Nortel in Toronto as a
co-op student and I was given the task
of tracking down a really complicated
bug that would take down this automatic
call distribution system every couple of
months this was a system that would
distribute calls geographically across
Canada for for the
main customers Air Canada so if people
called in after-hours on the East Coast
the calls would get routed to support
people Manning the phones on the West
Coast because it was three hours earlier
out there so they had these queues you
sit there on hold waiting in these call
queues and every couple of months the
system would just drop every call out of
the queue which Air Canada was quite
unhappy about understandably but nobody
could figure out why every couple of
months this would happen
they tried finding it for years and it
just they didn't see it so that was my
task as a co-op student and it was kind
of a joke there is a fix this like good
luck they didn't think I would get
anywhere they figured I would learn the
system from trying to track it down but
anyway I printed out the source code on
this huge wide the wide dot matrix pages
we had back then taped it to the walls
of all the hallways in northern telecom
there and at after-hours I always put
that in the floor and I would have these
highlighters different colored
highlighters and I'll be crawling around
on the floor and on the walls and a
chair I could stand on to reach the
higher things and I would just sort of
manually debug everything and try to
track down the flow of this thing and it
was nasty and in the end after three and
a half months it turned out to be a
global variable collision two separate
pieces of the code and completely
unrelated had the same name for a
variable and it was global changed in
one place at exactly the wrong time
would cause this other code to go crazy
and the C compiler at the time had no
way of informing us that that was
happening and it was just crazy and then
I started adding variables and scope to
PHP I remembered that there's no way
that in PHP I'm gonna be spending three
and a half months tracking down
something like this that's [ __ ] so
in PHP if you were gonna step on a
global you have to damn well declare the
fact inside the method or a function
that you're going to step on the global
so you have the dollar Global's array
with a huge capital letters this is a
global or
have to declare this out the function
global right so you can't accidentally
step on the global in PHP let's change a
little bit now with the Auto capturing
of the arrow functions that's coming
which worries me a little bit the first
time a bug appears because of Auto
capturing and arrow functions I'm gonna
go kick Nikita register Global's without
register Global's we wouldn't be here
honestly
register Global's enabled users who had
no idea how the web worked to build
dynamic pages to put up an HTML form
name age address as the field names and
then add tags that just said echo name
or if age is greater than 19 without
thinking about anything the fact that
field names became variable names in PHP
was the killer feature in the early days
of the web where people didn't even have
to think about how it worked it just
worked also context there was no Java
Script you couldn't do cross side
scripting you couldn't do any of the
things that in later years you could do
with register Global's turned on magic
quotes magic quotes was me being lazy
I admit that one this was not a good
solution but it took me a while to
discover that I should probably be
careful about letting user data into SQL
queries I had already written this big
system for the University of Toronto and
I had dozens of PHP files and say ah man
I have to go through and then filter all
my SQL stuff and all my input data
forget it I'll just do it once and I'll
turn on the flag turn on magic quotes
and have PHP do it for me because I was
too lazy to edit my my files so yeah
that's I don't have a good excuse for
that one other than laziness but it also
comes back to my six-month thing I
always thought I was six months away
from the end of life of PHP right this
was a tool primarily for me
that other people started using but
whatever I mean once that new thing came
along that fixes all the problems we
would all switch to that I could never
have imagined I'd still be talking about
this thing 25 years later so on the
consistency thing on saying that hey
it's perfectly consistent do you realize
that every single array function is
needle haystack and every single string
function is haystack Neil perfect
consistency right so the consistency in
PHP is vertical not horizontal because
of the way it grew organically right so
different people wrote the various
extensions so when you're talking to the
Oracle database using OCI 8 the
functions that talk to Oracle from PHP
are almost a one-to-one mapping of the
underlying seed library functions or the
API functions provided by Oracle same
with the MySQL functions and the other
database functions and they all across
PHP even the string functions are direct
one-to-one mapping of Lib C functions
right so the argument order and the
names come from the underlying libraries
that were wrapping where PHP is a very
thin wrapper basically just exposing
these C libraries directly to you
getting horizontal consistency across a
diverse set of underlying libraries
would have taken a hell a lot of
planning and organizing and sort of
predicting the future the web was moving
so fast there was just no way that that
would happen we needed a tool right here
and now the web was growing like that
and if I had sat around worrying about
horizontal consistency we also wouldn't
be here today
all right a little bit more current
stuff 73 hopefully everyone in this room
have at least looked at 73 hopefully
you're in the middle of migrating
everything to 73 does anyone in here
still running php5 you're killing me man
[Laughter]
I was expecting maybe one or two hands
to go up but the whole back of the room
lit up okay anyway so in seven three
also in seven zero for you folks in 71
and 72 there are some nice cool new
features but in 73 we've made hair Doc's
look a little nicer because the ending
tag doesn't have to be on in the left
column so whatever that's indented by is
the same indentation you'll see in the
output so if it's in four spaces then
four spaces will be removed from the
content continuing switch continue is
probably wrong if it's a continue inside
the switch that's inside a loop people
might expect that that continue will
continue the loop it doesn't it acts
just like a break when you do a continue
in the switch so PHP 7/3 has a warning
that says this probably bleeeh continued
to it either should be a break or
continue to so if you see these and the
and you did mean that break here then
just change it to a damn break list
references both the long since X and the
short subtext now support references
trailing comma without in function calls
now we had kind of forgotten that and
there in 72 we added trailing commas
support to most things but we didn't add
it to this one it's also a new monotonic
timer function if you're doing any sort
of timing in your PHP scripts currently
373 you're going to be relying probably
on micro time to do this timing which is
pretty broken because micro time relies
on the system clock if you have ntpd
running ntpd can speed up slow down stop
even make your clock go backwards by
actually I don't think anything can
could make it go backwards but could
make it stop for a little while your
sister an administrator can arbitrarily
change the system clock and make it go
backwards so if you're timing something
and your end time is before your start
time things get weird right and all just
the fact that ntpd can slow down
the clock a little bit just to sync it
with the NCPD time also means that your
timing is not gonna be right the
monotonic timer function will always
click forward one second per second and
this is really what you should be using
to time things there's a cool new fpm
get status function so you can write
very pretty dashboards kind of like the
Apache scoreboard where you can see what
each request is doing you know in Apache
you can do like a status / status and
get the scoreboard you can now write
something similar if you're running F
p.m. it's countable one of the big
changes in pH P 7 - that makes upgrading
really really difficult sometimes is
that count complains if it's called on
things that aren't countable so if it's
not an array or not an object that
implements the countable interface it
complains we saw that a lot of people
were calling his array or instance of
countable to try to figure out if foo is
countable now you're cold you really
should know what type of variably you
might be dealing with here but that's
not really the PHP way in PHP you never
know what the hell is in a variable
because you've written code well you
have methods that can return six
different types based on all kinds of
different things and so you don't know
so you have to check can I actually
count this so there's a new accountable
function in PHP 73 that just reduces
this boilerplate to something a little
less nasty
also to avoid the reset usage like
people will call reset to get the first
key of an associative array and that
also moves the array pointer which means
that you can't call it on something that
doesn't have storage you've probably
tried to do like a reset on a function
call that returns an array and you end
up getting an error right with a Reiki
first nor a key last you can now get the
first and last keys very quickly without
any side effects there's a whole bunch
of cool DC and sccp optimizations in in
73 which I'll talk about in a bit some
other changes the big one here from a
sort of a stuff that will break your
code is the pcre to upgrade it should be
rare
the main difference there are actually
quite a few differences between 1 and 2
but in pcre - the main one that you will
likely hit are invalid character classes
you know how you in character class you
have sort of in square brackets a - Zed
for example and that means all the
letters from a does that if you have a -
backslash s so a - whitespace what does
that mean who knows and in peace Yuri
one says we don't know what this is so
that - in the middle must mean a literal
so this is a a - and white space in pcre
1 which makes some sense right because
it's in an invalid character class so
it's not actually going to be a class
it's not gonna be arranged in pcre -
they've said while you try to build a
range this is an invalid range this is
an error and it won't compile the
regular expression for you and you'll
see a big warning in your air log if you
ever look at your error log which I
don't think many people do you'll see a
big warning unable to compile regular
expression and your code will break the
count thing in 72 is just noise in the
error log it actually still
it's the same value so it doesn't break
your application this one breaks your
application because it won't compile the
records and that wreckage will not do
anything right
so when you do the upgrade 273 make sure
you scan your error log and your unit
tests and everything for invalid or
errors from PC are you saying it
couldn't compile your regular expression
and most of the time all you have to do
is go in and add a back slash in front
of that - to make it a literal because
that's how it worked before in PCR 81 it
was treated as a literal - if you had a
back slash to it it'll be valid in both
PC R u 1 and PC or you - and it'll do
the same thing read the migration
document if you have extensions read the
upgrading internals document that helps
you figure out what you need to fix in
your extensions for the folks still on
PHP 5 you know a lot of these to read
right so there's migration 7 0 71 72 73
if you wait a few more months you'll
have another one to read 74 it gets
harder and harder the longer you wait
all right 73 Dimitri in Saint Petersburg
has been having lots of fun with DCE
escape analysis and sccp
sparse conditional constant propagation
sounds very complicated but it's
actually not complicated at all it's
kind of fun you can dump up codes after
the optimization pass with a tricky
little set of settings like this our
cache optimization level - once to turn
on all the bits and set it to hex to
20,000 it'll spit out the opcodes after
the optimization run and you will see
for a simple script like this that just
has a function and because of the
Global's and PHP this is a local
variable there can be absolutely no side
effect from setting a equals one and
since we don't use dollar a in anywhere
and just return zero this is useless
this assignment serves no purpose
whatsoever in PHP 71 and earlier
we still create the opcodes for it so we
have the assign opcode that assigns one
$2 a and we return 0 7 2 & 7 3
the optimizer sees this as being
redundant and doesn't even generate the
opcodes which means they don't get cash
to not cash and that's really where
you're executing from so essentially
it's just deleting that line of code and
that never gets run which also means
your code runs slightly faster because
there's one less opcode to step through
more complicated things so here are the
CV lines it's basically just saying
where the inputs the input arguments are
stored these aren't like executable our
codes is just saying these are stored in
these four places then seven one will
happily concatenate do the concatenation
s1 and s2 s3 and s4 and then they
concatenate there's result together here
t6 and t7 get concatenated together so
now we have the final dollar X then we
overwrite dollar X probably right t5 to
X then we overwrite it with 0 and we
return X 72 and 73 see through all this
mess and see that hey all this
concatenation gets overwritten in the
very next line plus X is always 0 so we
don't even need X right so it replaces
all this mess just with the return 0
opcode no come Katz no creating a
variable X nothing that stuff never
happened and try the trick it stuff like
this it figures it out still so here
we're only incrementing a we're also
setting B so that result but we're since
we don't use it the B part gets
eliminated in 7 3 it has gotten smarter
with array stuff so in 7 - it couldn't
figure out arrays like this more and
also objects so in 7 3
it looks up one level to see off to test
for side effects so if you instantiate
an object like this if there's no whole
destructor and no constructor
then there was absolutely no side effect
possible from a instantiating dollar a
here and even setting a property
there's no setter up here either so the
opcodes just removes everything and it
just returns X if in that same example
we added the structure now you can see
that it did not remove those off codes
anymore because now there could possibly
be a side effect once dollar a fall saw
the scope and this structure is called
there could be a side effect there even
though in this case the structure is
empty it doesn't actually check because
that would be another level to check it
doesn't actually check if the
destructors MJ just checks if it's there
also it's smart about arrays now in 73
so here if you kind of follow this it
doesn't matter if X is true or false e
will only ever returning the first
element of the array so all this stuff
gets replaced with just to return 0
because the optimizer sees that no
matter what the input is the output is
always 0 so everything in between can go
away since there are no side effects and
you can delete all that code and you can
go kind of crazy you have code like this
right the optimizer tells us that all
this does is echo one return for you can
totally try to make your way through it
and validate the fact that it will
always only echo one return for that's a
lot of op codes that have been
eliminated so like I told and most
people don't talk too much about how
much faster your code is under PHP 73
because if it's drastically faster under
73 you've written code like this right
it should be 5% maybe 10% faster if you
stretch it over like 7 1 7 2 it should
not be like 30 40 % faster
if it's 30 40 % faster then it's the
optimizer eliminating all your code
basically deleting your code and saying
you're an idiot
all this code doesn't need to be here
alright so this is the real performance
gain you can expect from 73 the last bar
here right so going all the way back to
5/3 this is in requests per second 154
requests per second for the front page
of WordPress for 98 versus 520 today for
it and latency has also been dropping
nice the hundred and 40 milliseconds
using PHP 5/3 down to 38 now no seconds
on my test box so the actual absolute
numbers don't matter but the the
relation does matter right things have
gotten faster every single version we
get a little bit faster and memory has
shrunk quite a bit running on 5 3 we
need 140 Meg's today we need 15 makes to
serve up WordPress version support this
is where we are if you're running
anything other than PHP 72 and 73 you're
behind and you need to upgrade if you're
still running 7-0 do you realize PHP 7
was released in 2015 an Internet on the
web that's old it's old code PHP 7-0 is
no longer supported in any way
whatsoever not even security fixes are
being done so if you're still there and
the for the folks still running PHP 5
it's just irresponsible
honestly she'll be running code that old
on anything that might be important
I mean if it's if it's your blog or
something fine no problem right but if
it's something that's dealing with
customer data or anything that is
actually sensitive you can't be running
code that's 10 plus years old you can't
do it all right
stack analysis one of my side projects
that I started and hand it off to
someone smarter than me which is sort of
my pattern I start things and I get them
going I get in just to the point where
they're useful enough for someone else
to continue it as opposed to completely
starting their own thing easy-to-install
Composer require the fan fan very simple
config file if you have a standard sort
of composer set up with a source
directory in the vendor directory you
can tell it this is my source directory
and my vendor directory scan it but
don't report errors for that one so this
is the exclude analysis directory list
so it'll still be part of those other
the map you could because you need all
the dependencies you need all the types
from those because you're calling into
them but you don't want to hear about
any errors in other people's code and
then run vendor bin fan if you've never
done it before you're gonna get hundreds
if not thousands of errors reported
about your code you can add some filters
and say I don't want to know about this
type of error and there's a whole bunch
of different filters available checks a
ton of things these days this is just a
very small list of things that'll check
that's a quick example I have a class
like this with a function that takes
three arguments the first one takes
either a string or an integer called
Union here the next one takes an array
and in the native type in PHP you can
just say it's an array with fan you can
give it a more specific type you can say
this is an integer array and fan will
check that it's never passed something
that's not an integer in that array and
then the last one that's a shaped array
and that's actually saying this array
must have a key name mode with the value
that's a string and the key name max
with the value that's an integer I
forget something that doesn't match this
definition of the function fan will
complain so here these first three calls
were okay we have string integer array
and a shape the Ray that matches this
time we have an integer which is fine as
well because this is
either string or int and this one is
fine what did I even change here doesn't
matter then this one is not fine the
first argument is an array right and
that's not part of that Union so fan
complains saying that the argument one
is an array but the function takes
integer or string another example here
here are the shaped array is missing the
mode element so it complains about that
so these are some of the things that you
can expect to see running fan another
tool much newer than fan fan is 3 years
old now I think 4 years old maybe lower
head profiling is a cool new thing that
we've worked on that Etsy guy named Adam
super smart guy wrote this thing it's a
little bit like RP spy I think there's a
PI spy as well you run it like this you
can attach it to any PHP process whether
it be a PHP fpm whether it is httpd with
mod PHP so PHP is running inside HTTP B
does matter or just a standalone PHP
process and the sampling frequency by
default is 99 milliseconds I think if
you don't specify it 99 not 100 because
if you set it to exactly a hundred there
can be some timing issues where you
happen to exactly miss something because
things tend to happen in hundreds of
milliseconds as opposed to every 99
milliseconds so by offsetting it
slightly you're more likely to not run
into any sort but you can also change it
yourself in this case I've said it to a
lot of nanoseconds that's 200
milliseconds and I'm checking a script
that's just sleeping for one second so
every 200 milliseconds I'm asking PHP
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
what do you think and it comes back
every time with a little back trace
telling me I'm in I'm sleeping and I was
called from Maine right because this
runs for one second then we check every
200 milliseconds we get five answers
and then we get a no such process at the
end because PHP has stopped here is an
example of attaching to a PHP fpm
process that's currently serving
WordPress and you can see that the
whether you doing response is a lot more
complicated now the stack trace is much
deeper you can also get the memory usage
from each frame if you pass minus M and
here if anybody wants a project to
contribute to it'd be great to have some
support for per for call grind or some
other way of visualizing the memory here
there would be a nice one too to add
support for it sits on the to-do list
just nobody's gotten to that part yet we
have the numbers the hard part has been
done we're getting the numbers out of
every stack frame but we need to
visualize it somehow for the straight
what are you doing how much time are you
spending in places we have output we
have a flame graph that you can generate
there are some scripts that come with
PHP spy one is the stack collapse the
other is flame graph which a Perl script
of all things just kind of cool and what
you get out of this is a flame graph
that looks like this so this is me
running fan sorry running PHP spy on fan
so if i zoom into some of this I can see
like here and analyze and get updated
context calls into this other thing
which visit statement list which calls
into analyze and get updated context
again and op the tree we can go we can
follow it all the way up we use this
thing at Etsy at ton we have a gear man
pool of servers that handle gear man
jobs some of these are quite
long-running we also have servers doing
cron jobs and again some of these run
for quite a while and sometimes they run
a lot longer than we think they should
and it's hard to know what the heck
they're doing because we try it I like
on our development servers and it never
runs for more than six minutes or
something and then in production this
thing has been running for 40 minutes
what's it doing right we can't replicate
it but with PHP spy we can hop on the
production server attached to the
running process without slowing it down
and see what it's doing where is it
spending its time on PHP spies in magic
because you don't have to compile PHP in
any sort of special way you don't have
to have debug symbols you don't have to
have anything you can have a completely
stripped optimized GCC - o3 compiled
binary and it'll still give you this
output and it does it by simply looking
at the kernel memory you have to run to
this root which is I guess a bit of a
problem for some but it's because it
needs to look at the kernel basically it
knows the offsets for the different
versions of PHP so it knows where the eg
Global's live for example the executed
Global's live in memory for PHP 73 right
that's another certain offset and it
knows where all these places are so it's
just looking at memory and seeing what's
changing it also has an option to spy on
them variable so you can track you can
set every ninety nine milliseconds tell
me the value of this variable and you
can track how that's changing over time
so so there's a lot of front-end stuff
that could be added to this to make it
even cooler Adam has mostly been
focusing on the back-end part he also
hates public speaking so if you want a
project where you can have pretty much a
guaranteed accepted conference talk for
come contribute to PHP spy add the cool
front-end support for some of this stuff
and submit the talk and I guarantee you
it will be accepted because it's really
cool and Adams not going to mind he
would love someone else just talk about
PHP spy for you for us all right
Pete's b7 for coming out leave those
here type properties yeah if you don't
care about performance you can find but
I mean hopefully we'll come up with ways
of counteracting the performance hit
that this is going to take there is some
obviously this is also why we're not
going to do it for standard variables
because
every single time you modify one of
these we have to add a type check so
think of a loop in the reader while I
plus wild dollar I plus plus write this
thing every time through the loop we
ratifying the variable for properties
that's less of a problem presumably
you're not doing while dollar this I I
plus plus right
hopefully not people typically don't
make iterators property over their
classes right so you tend to write less
to them which is why the performance hit
on this put on properties isn't as big
as it would be typing regular variables
arrow functions recently accepted these
two are similar or identical so you can
see why is auto captured here from the
other scope you can have nested there
are functions you can also put types in
if you wanted to you can add a type here
you can put colon return type as well on
it pretty simple serialization has
always been an issue in PHP there are
various problems with the wakeup and
sleep and wake up things magic methods
sterilize and unsterilized gives you a
way of controlling exactly how your
class is going to be serialized and when
it uncie realizes how it's going to
answer allies instead of relying on some
of the weird side effects that you end
up with in the current mechanism it's a
new null coalescing assignment operator
coming so these two are equivalent weak
references
PHP is reference counted which means
when a variable goes out of scope there
are no more references to that
particular piece of memory it gets freed
in the sense that it's available for for
reuse within PHP if you have something
like a cash system or anything where you
want to you want to avoid stopping
something from being collected or being
referenced counted
if you have a weak reference it doesn't
count as a reference so they say a
equals something that comes back from
your database for example and you in the
cache it and you said B equals the
reference to this and now you have a
reference count of two then you might
also have a cache reference to it now if
both a and B go our the scope then this
thing should be deleted freed but if the
cache is still referencing it the cache
will stop it from returning the memory
for the system the cache should then be
rewritten to get a weak reference
instead then it doesn't count so it's
only the two main references that count
and once the two main references go away
its reference counted and it's freed and
the weak reference dies now the cool new
feature is our cache pre loading it
basically loads the use of space code
that start up and then any code you have
any classes any functions
it's as if they were internal for the
rest of the life of of that PHP instance
that makes it harder to change that code
obviously because if you need to make
changes deploy a new version then you
can't just have PHP stat it and
recompile it because it's only looking
at this stuff on startup or you could
force you'd have to do some more
complicated things to forcibly compile
its inspired by Java hotspot VM and it
works like this so if say you have code
that just has a class a echoes out a in
the constructor you probably have an
autoloader and when you do a new a the
other though the triggers loads in that
PHP file a dot PHP and the class is run
constructor runs we get a in the
preloaded world if in your i and i you
have app cache preload point it to a
script in this case preload PHP in that
PHP script all you have to do is up
cache compiled file whatever you want to
preload by whatever logic you want in my
case I wrote a little preload function
that I can pass the file names to that I
want to preload and IAP cache compiled
file those
all names so in this case when I run
that same script PHP this script here
with the auto loader you can see that
when I run it it doesn't say that the
auto loader was triggered it just
outputs a because on startup it preloads
a and that class is registered this
might seem like a lot of stuff that
doesn't necessarily give you a whole lot
of benefit it helps you a little bit
because even though app cache compiles
and caches the opcodes
there still is a little bit more work to
do to bring those up codes into scope
and to create the class in this
particular request for example you can
have five classes all with the same name
write in different PHP files and
depending on whatever context you're
loading one file over another you pick
the right class out of op cache and
create that for that request in the
preloaded world you can only have one
class with that name you can't preload
two classes with the same name that just
wouldn't work you would get a
redefinition error but they're also kind
of illustrates that there is a little
bit extra work involved
if you don't preload something so
there's slightly faster but where it
really becomes interesting is when
combined with FFI foreign function
interface lets you create this FFI
object directly from an underlying c
library in this case this example is
really simple this is just loading in
Lib C and defining this is base we think
of this as a header file right so this
is a header file you know the end that
just has the prototype for the printf
function and we're telling it grab this
from Lib C dot so6 now off of this FF I
object you created you can now call
anything that were defined any
prototypes that were in that header file
you now have access to directly and you
can call directly into the C printf are
completely useless because PHP already
has a printf function that does exactly
that basically
to test it out I went and grabbed a
library called gif Inc alpha github it's
a very simple little library the header
file looked like this the top two lines
are something I added you can ignore
those but this is exactly the header
files to come with the library the hello
file and it just defines three functions
nuke if GE Nuka of GE add frame and
close gift right so this is a little
library that creates animated gifts it
has this somewhat complicated structure
for the gift Heather
number of frames color depth things like
that to load that in because I added
these two I set a scope and I told it
which shared library this is in that's
the only two things I added to the
header file otherwise I just pasted it
directly and I can just load that header
file now and it does everything and it
compiles the code and creates this FFI
object and now I can just play with the
FFI object you still need to know a
little bit of C you need to understand
for example that this color argument to
new gif the fourth argument to new gif
if we look at it here you can see you
get the filename width and the height
these are just long so that's easy
enough but this one here you end eight
pointer Oh what is that right if you're
in the PHP world now you're looking at C
pointers you kinda have to know what
that means that this is actually an
array of you ain't eight unsigned
integers that you're passing in so in
this space you have to create this array
and you can say FF I knew you in Tate
and I want 12 of them because these are
the colors that I'm passing in and I
pass in RGB values for these colors then
I can call the function for these the
simple Long's we can we look at the the
thing we look at these go now wrong key
you look at these and you have
- no enough seed to know that this is
just a PHP long will do here and PHP
long we'll do here
char pointer that's just a string just
pass a string in this case again integer
integer it's fine to just pass a PHP
integer in here this one you have to
create separately right great that
separately do a bit of loops add a frame
different colors every time through
close the gif and the result is that
which is kind of cool but pre-loading +
FF I is super interesting because this
step is deadly slow the FF I load you do
not want to do this on the per request
basis but if you preload this thing on
server start up all your F of I blocks
are going to get compiled and added
directly in to PHP as if they were an
extension I can see a whole bunch of our
very thin extensions that just wrap see
libraries I can see these being
converted to pre loaded FF eyes that you
can just compose or install directly
because they're really just PHP scripts
so they can be managed through composer
and also all the data marshalling like
all this other stuff is just PHP code
right the amount of C that's in here is
creating that header file and then a
little bit of creating the types maybe
that you need a C developer for all this
other stuff people who only know PHP can
happily maintain the other parts of the
extension there's only so much that's
actually needed for these the C part
right and you need a C developer to get
the base right but then from then on any
little change to that extension can be
done in PHP managed through composer
it'll it'll increase or broaden the the
users the amount of users that can help
maintain extensions and I think it can
kind of change the world for us we'll
see
all right I know I'm pretty much out of
the time but one last little rain so
these 25 years also included having a
son 17 years ago me hacking on some PHP
stuff gain on the ThinkPad Mac's were
cool back then so I had a sticker I
never really converted it to the whole
Mac thing oh yeah little Karl being like
three days old at that point I think two
days old maybe a little bit later anyone
in here remember Linux talk college
school yes so Karl would run around he
was really really good at finding the
on/off switch on anything he would run
from booth to booth at this big Linux
tax conference and he would find the off
switch and turn off these servers which
didn't I mean he was a cute kid and he
had his PHP shirt on so they couldn't
get too upset at him but there were a
few that were really grumbling because
he would circle back and do it again and
again now he's 17 he's driving playing
video games in the car right it's a
completely different world that we live
in now and he has hair down to his
elbows yeah very very different and it's
making me feel rather old when my son
comes and picks me up also over these 25
years I used to go to Australia every
year we had some great hacker gatherings
this is andrew tridgell famous for our
sink and many other things
lena stalls a bunch of other AHS hackers
in here you can see this was before LCD
panels or anything right this is this is
old old school some other highlights for
the 25 years this is me in India at the
conference I don't have a suit like that
these conference organizers thought that
while there are speakers are so
important they should be wearing suits
so they Photoshop me into a suit and
there are these huge posters all over
the town of me in this suit looking very
important I guess and I saw that I know
what the hell this was another highlight
this was in Sri Lanka anyone know who
this might be
sitting here you're cheating yes the
arthur c clarke one of them so that you
can't see that okay you have good eyes
yes arthur c clarke lived in sri lanka
for years and years and years he came to
a PHP conference and said right in the
front row asked questions completely
engaged and it was super cool to teach
PHP to arthur c clarke although the
really cool thing about this particular
conference was that this was in 2005 in
december 2004 there was the huge indian
ocean earthquake i don't know if you
remember but there was a massive tsunami
after that that slammed in sri lanka a
lot of people died out of that came
something called Sahana and the Sahana
project is a disaster relief project and
i talked to the folks there when I was
there and talked through some of the
things that they could do with PHP in
Sahana and this is one of the things
that makes me still contribute to PHP
makes me still feel like it's worthwhile
even doing some of the things when I get
slammed with flames and blog posts
online about all those all the bad
decisions I've made over the years but
then I go to Sri Lanka and I see
something like this kid at the
University and also a guy working for
the government there got together and
built a disaster
relief in a box management type system
where basically if relief comes in Plane
full of diapers comes in someone on the
ground will say we have diapers they're
over in hangar number three whatever
same for whatever else comes in so you
can keep track of aid coming into the
country
you can also there's also people finder
so this is a very simple front-end for
the people finder and there's also a
mobile app now where the rescue workers
ask the person their name take them to
shelter number three and the enter that
into the mobile app and then you're
online you check where's my grandmother
put the name of your grandmother in and
it'll tell you yes she's been found
she's over there right and there are
seven eight nine different modules like
that and the the value is that this can
be spun up in three minutes
right this is just a package that you
spin up super super quickly and it has
been used now in the 50 plus disasters
around the world knowing that PHP has
literally probably saved someone's life
makes all that online grief completely
irrelevant this is a tool PHP is not
important what you do with it is
important if you save someone's life
with something you've built that's
awesome
arguing about the color of the hammer
used to build that thing it's just
moronic and all these flames about the
technologies and stuff we can't lose
track of what we're doing here why we're
programming we're programming to solve a
problem and hopefully it's a problem
that actually matters right it's a very
nice quote from the second national
secretary of defense of the Philippines
who set that right directly targeted as
Sahana because he saw what Sahana did
for a big disaster in the Philippines so
it was a much slight thing back then
so work on things that matter to you
please I see a lot of people that have
left why there are a lot of people I
don't see in this room and in the other
conference rooms that I go to that were
there 10 years ago but now they're
middle managers they're not programming
anymore they burned out
they changed jobs and sometimes that
that's just sort of the progression then
they make sense for them and there are
good managers there are also a lot of
really crappy middle managers out there
there were great programmers and they
become crappy managers because they
don't feel like they can keep up it's
too much work to keep up with how fast
technology is moving which is kind of
code for that they've lost interest
they're not more than they motivated
enough to actually sit and read about
things in the evenings they have a
families now and it takes more time and
I understand that I have a family but
there's still this Drive there's this
passion and motivation that makes me
continue if you don't have that you will
burn out and especially the younger
folks in the room you love programming
but will you still be programming when
you're 50 60 70 maybe you don't want to
that's fine perfectly fine but if you
want to if you love what you're doing
really look at what you're actually
doing and don't worry that much about
the tool if you switch tools fine it's
it's what you build with it that's
important I'm sure there are all kinds
of geek arguments about paintbrushes
what's the best paintbrush that painters
might have internally doesn't matter
what people remember are the actual
paintings right who made well I was
gonna say Michelangelo but that's he's a
big PT guy right so but I mean who
created mo built Mozart's piano if
you're a music geek you probably know I
mean maybe you know but who built the
piano isn't as important as the actual
music that was created with it right and
that's what we're doing we're building
things
and things come out of this I think I am
squarely in the middle of this chart I
can code a little bit I'm not a very
good coder I'm sort of a mediocre coder
I don't particularly like programming
I built PHP because it was too
complicated the tools I had at the time
just weren't up for the actual task I
thought it took me too long and was too
hard and too tedious so in order to
program less I spent the next next 25
years programming something that would
let me program lasts it made no sense
but still it did allow me to build
things along the way that actually
affected people's lives and that still
keeps me going and I'm very very
thankful for the Y's there are a lot of
Y's that have helped out on the PHP
project over the years people just love
to code doesn't really matter what
they're coding they just sort of love
the act of coding they love the journey
they don't really care where they're
going kind of like flying right I hate
flying
but I spend my life flying I fly a lot
because I want to get to somewhere not
because I just like sitting in this
smelly little tube with a bunch of
people all right
and saving that there are lots of
dreamers out there that have absolutely
no basis in reality to know if they can
build some of these dreams and that you
need a little bit of grounding to figure
out if this grand idea you have can
actually work all right that's my rant
and I know I'm over time sorry
conference folks so slides are there a
couple of links thank you
[Applause]